Now it's your turn.
Let's do a quiz on write-back caches.
Suppose we have a direct map cache and
this is one entering that cache.
And all of the axises we will
do will map to that one entry.
The valid bit starts out at 0.
The dirty bit starts out at 1.
And the tag starts out at A.
The processor does the following
sequence of axises.
It reads A, reads B, writes B,
reads C, reads D, writes D.
And all of these, A, B, C, and D,
map to the same place in the cache.
The question for
you, is, after these accesses,
what is the new state of the cache?
Also you need to determine how many
cache misses do we have in this sequence
of accesses and how many write-backs to
memory will happen during the sequence.